very quickly mentioned Thor mostly so we
can show this picture sure why would you
be embarrassed
a lot of dieting and exercise also
parently is this true the people this is
odd so people come up to you and they
want you to tell a specific joke oh
they're just come and tell me for a joke
like yeah go you know the joke about the
Thor spends a night with this woman and
the next morning he says I have to tell
you who I am you know I'm Thor she says
you're Thor I can hardly walk
Hulk though moves in a strange direction
in that the hope finds romance in this
phone you saw it happen our alert
congratulations course this film is the
first production from Team Downey yeah
yep
and misses a beat here great team she's
fantastic she could produce the showcase
her regards another team Downey
production yes when is this much less to
do with in the movie about thank you
she'll bring it in on time and under
budget could you just as a favor because
I know that you know some stars like to
give unusual names could you call him or
her up here Danny I think a lot of
actors when they get roles like this
they have to say oh yeah no it's a
thrill dude but for you this is genuine
could you post these incredibly sweet
pictures this is you as a young boy
this one this is amazing you were I
think back at your house and you found
this yeah that was genuinely yours that
was my first ever spider-man costume
yeah which my lovely mum who said
tonight kept for me
and were you one of those kids you'd
like wore to funerals and weddings thing
that thing still stinks today that can
make that thing wearable that the
spider-man outfit as we knew it is gone
now
No well yes yes it is basically
essentially in this film I have a new
suit which Tony Stark gave me it's an
upgrade and it's too fantastical to
exist in real life so I essentially
there it is that's the first time I've
seen it where looks great I don't know
okay
like offset which seems a little tragic
contextualise I was filming in New York
and New York overseas the home of the
character so some of it had to take
place there and we were on his Street on
Bleecker Street and just around the
corner was a cafe and it was in New York
as I think in a lot of America the
perhaps can just the paparazzi can get
in front of the camera they go hey get
out of my shot to the DOP who's moving
the camera around so it's it's
extraordinary and they were everywhere
this day they were just stubborn more of
them than they were crew so this is
getting a little dirty because they
can't follow me into a cafe surely in
the men know they can't but you're
growing on it caffeine I went yeah it's
a French word for a coffee house I'm
gonna go around the Congo I went into
ok2say
[Applause]
fair enough
so I go to this cafe fully regale that I
don't really know if I could finish done
it and I walked him and it was very New
York that everyone sort of Turner what
that and the coffee's were sort of half
between mouths and tables and people
stopped talking and then I just we got a
table I had blood and cuts on me and
encash human and the minute the wait
said yeah sure everyone just went anyway
I said st. Joseph's originally
originally or dish and no offense is
meant by my incredulity here that's
right
but you were originally auditioned for
Thor yep okay why did you go with this
[Applause]
I think it was the hair it's my brother
from another mother but now you're the
sexiest man alive it's official is the
sexiest man alive I'm number five on
heats weird crush list is it's the worst
know what just so awful
yeah you a little self-conscious you
know I'm finally at an age I'm 36 years
old I really don't care about anything
like that anymore which is a wonderful
thing
and then this happened and then I
started to realize just how not sexy I
am
oh stop I swear to God I swear to God I
have a lot of moments where I'll be like
walking out and I like like I open up
the door and I go I could do that a lot
sexier that was you doing it without the
special effects anyway it is not even
Jeremy Renner
Jeremy Renner was really on a grass
I wouldn't say this woman's fleeing for
her life
about that actually when you got to say
you were a bit like that you were kind
of found Garlin around me yeah we shot
ant-man and but I was alone on that I
was like working in a in a bubble pretty
much and then all of a sudden I'm
standing around and seeing Robert Downey
jr. and the Iron Man suit and seeing
Chris Evans and they're all there I've
seen the movies and I felt like I was I
was 10 years old it was crazy
did you read any of the touching the arm
thing yeah yeah I saw I saw Sebastian
Stan getting his arm the silver arm on
and it was whit I was like I was
watching somebody bathing I'm not
supposed to see this but I did I went
over and I felt be on Chris Evans had to
run to the bathroom really quick so so
he asked the prop guy he was could you
just hold this he was holding his shield
rhenium pretty cool I must say well you
a child start to have a runner right
know you tweeted a picture of yourself I
did as a child this face could sell any
product on earth look at look at this
worms look like
[Applause]
it's a huge compliment
yeah Ruffalo in your house your kids are
growing up with the Incredible Hulk as
it bad right is that a terrible thing or
an amazing thing well it was amazing in
the beginning because I could get him to
do stuff I mean like go brush your teeth
your dad's the Hulk and now I try it and
it doesn't work so well left them
scarred for life yeah it doesn't play
anymore they're like yo big whoop at
some point you would have had to have
got angry you'd have had to turn into
I've done that that doesn't work after a
while right get green and big I believe
it was Michael brought up his chest
because your chest in Black Panther
we've got his shoes in Black Panther
this this caused a sensation
there was an orthodontist that came
forward and I said about this young
woman who came in yeah orthodontist had
a patient this this this girl who was
watching Black Panther and I guess
during that scene she had her retainers
in and she clenched her jaws so tight
that she broke her retainers and that
kind of went viral and a buddy of mine
had sent it to me like hey man have you
seen this and I was like no that's wild
how do you even do that and so I saw I
sent her a DM I was like hey I'm I'm
sorry and I
can I pay for your retainer or whatever
I saw her to pay for it and she was like
no no no that's why I have insurance and
I she was a very proper answer I was
like okay cool
she said you know if you're ever in the
Bay Area just you know let me know and I
would love to take a picture too and I
said okay cool and I was a trade-off
Josh Brolin this summer
you must you're gonna be causing like
nerdgasm yes in people because like
toward nerds won't know they won't
understand cuz you're either Gaza Ming
yes they'll be happy they're Gaza me
because I like how confused they just be
knows in Avengers of energy war but
you're also in Deadpool to like oh like
what's the timeline what's happening I
don't understand it at three weeks apart
coming out three weeks apart and
Avengers did well quite well and pool
will break all those records
[Applause]
obviously you know I'm this is a lot of
your films they're in your intro but you
haven't done these kind of big
blockbusters with CGI and explosions and
things you like you nice when you do
milk or No Country for Old Men it
doesn't matter because you started so
therefore you can get away with anything
you want this seems so unlikely that you
have now learned how to do the voices
from town yeah sort of yeah we love that
garbage TV crazy about it and when I was
here filming guardians we shot guardians
the galaxy here in London and and my
wife on I came out to visit and she fell
in love with this show TOWIE The Only
Way Is Essex it's this show that's like
basically their jersey shorts the Jersey
Shore from from here it's like this town
somewhere Essex I guess it's like I'm a
parrot a little bit and so when I hear
when I hear it all the time I just
started picking it up and started like I
could pick up their accent and do their
accent a little bit no no yeah I'm okay
it's gonna sound really embarrassing to
do in front of a whole room full of
Brits here but I'll try it anyways so
it's like so I want to say like a Suisse
car
they delight like Michael cheat on me
was in a beef are telling me he's I you
know you know unless you or whatever
[Applause]
we'll never be useful never be useful
but he's very good months and that's
what you
[Music]
you